[MUSIC PLAYING]
KYLE THIERMANN:
Hawaii is home to some
of the most beautiful
and diverse landscapes
in the world.
I first visited Hawaii
when I was a teenager.
The day I arrived, I remember
diving down under water,
opening my eyes,
and being struck
with the realization that
never before in my life
had I seen the color of
such deep blue water.
I've returned every year since.
But the water surrounding
these islands has a problem,
and it stems from
something we use every day.
How does wastewater
impact human health?
ERICA PEREZ: It can
impact it through skin,
bacterial infections,
gastrointestine infections.
KYLE THIERMANN:
Do you know anyone
who's been impacted
by that, like,
have gotten staph infections
or anything like that?
ERICA PEREZ: I have.
I have gotten staph
from the water. [LAUGHS]
And I also know people that
have gotten MRSA and other skin
infections.
KYLE THIERMANN: Erica
is working to protect
coral and the
coastal environments
from one of its biggest
threats, cesspools.
ERICA PEREZ: A
cesspool is essentially
also known as a dry well.
It's a hole that's in the
ground that is capped,
and it's used for residential
wastewater discharge.
So whatever is coming
from your toilet at home
goes into this underground
hole and is contained there.
KYLE THIERMANN: The
problem with cesspools
is that there's no
waste treatment.
This means that waste continues
to foster pathogens, bacteria,
and excess nutrients, which can
eventually seep out of the pit
and contaminate the groundwater.
In places like Puako, which
has a high water table,
the contaminated
ground water easily
makes its way into the ocean.
ERICA PEREZ: Researchers
from the University
of Hawaii, Hilo conducted dye
tracer studies here in Puako.
What they did is they placed
dye in toilets of homes
with cesspools and waited
to see how long it came out
along the shoreline.
And what they ended up finding
is that, from flush to reef,
it took about six hours to three
days to reach the shoreline.
KYLE THIERMANN: According to
Hawaii's Department of Health,
these cesspools release
approximately 55
million gallons of
untreated sewage
into the ground every day.
This means that water
contaminated with disease
could be making its way
into Hawaii's famed beaches.
So you have to ask, why are
cesspools still being used?
BRIAN LAMB: People
will give an argument,
our ancestors have been
pooping in holes forever.
Well, they also didn't
have cooking oils.
They didn't have these kind of
processed foods that we're now
eating that are going
into the ground.
KYLE THIERMANN: Brian Lamb,
a wastewater technician
on the Big Island,
showed me firsthand
what type of wastewater is
making its way into the ocean.
Not only have cesspools been
on Hawaii for generations,
the cost of installing a
cleaner, individual wastewater
system can be
prohibitive, especially
for low-income families.
But the current
systems will continue
to cause damage to
the reefs, which
are more than just a
tourist attraction that
bring in $1 million a day.
DANA REED: Coral reefs are one
of the most diverse ecosystems
that we have on our planet.
They protect us
from wave energy.
If we lose those coral reefs,
we no longer have protection,
and this causes a lot more
coastal erosion and water comes
up on the island.
The reefs themselves support
a huge amount of life.
Without coral reefs, all
of our fisheries collapse.
Coral reefs are an
incredibly important habitat
for the planet.
KYLE THIERMANN: But this habitat
is at a fragile turning point.
On a recent dive, I
saw the devastation
that's occurring to these
reefs, and it seemed to me
that not enough attention has
been paid to water quality.
DANA REED: The
Department of Health
has had one person
on the island of Maui
who is in charge of coastal
water quality monitoring.
That person recently retired
and has not yet been replaced.
So currently,
we're the only ones
doing any sort of water
quality testing on Maui.
KYLE THIERMANN: The
government is slowly
beginning to take
action, by banning
new cesspool construction
and offering tax
breaks for certain
properties to transition
to new wastewater systems.
But that still leaves
tens of thousands
of cesspools on the islands.
MICHAEL MONTGOMERY: Hawaii very
recently successfully banned
new cesspools, but
there's still a question
of how we're going to address
the legacy of, you know,
the 88,000 cesspools
that are in Hawaii.
And then most
importantly, the 19,000
that are actually near the
coast or near drinking water
supplies.
ERICA PEREZ: With
the ban on cesspools,
the Department of Health has
implemented a $10,000 tax
credit, so it can support
the financial cost
of transitioning
away from cesspools
to new, better technologies.
KYLE THIERMANN: It
became clear to me
that there's no easy
solution in sight.
But ultimately, the government,
along with home and business
owners will need
to work together
to find ways to protect humans
and the ocean environmentally,
or the Hawaii that we've come
to know and I've come to love
might never be the same.
Don't forget to subscribe
for more Seeker Stories.
And be sure to check
out this next episode,
where we look at how
feral pigs are also
threatening the survival
of Hawaii's coral reefs.